That was one of the sadomasochist books that was turned into a movie.
Do you remember this movie starring Dan Akroyd?
No,
Dan Akroyd.
Oh,
I do with Rosie O'donnell.
That's right.
It was a comedy,
right?
Was it supposed to be a comedy?
I mean it's,
it's beard was based off the story.
So I think Gary Marshal might've turned it into a comedy.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
Bizarre.
She played a slow person.
Yes,
yes.
No,
I have it.
But Sean Penn has also played a slow person,
but no one has quite done it the way Ben Stiller did.
Did you see that people were getting mad because people,
because some football player when as simple Jack,
the shorter oh boy.
Oh,
that's right.
Um,
but not just him.
There's a couple other people that went as simple jack for Halloween and they
were getting like,
you can't go with simple jack anymore.
You can't be a simple person.
A simple character like dumb characters are now out the window.
You can't be that anymore.
What happened?
What's going on with us?
Some weird new rules like popping up out of nowhere.
Like,
wait,
what Jack?
A parody of the thing,
like it was a,
it's a joke on a joke.
Play Simple Jack.
It's not that he's actually portraying a realistic portrayal of,
right,
right.
Simple.
Jack was a character.
Yeah.
Even in the movie,
simple.
John was a character in a movie,
wasn't like an actual person.
Yeah,
there it is.
Time.
There was a retard.
Wow.
Is that what it says in the movie?
Yeah.
It's a fake movie though,
but wow.
I liked the scene.
That's not that long ago.
And here's the thing,
that movie also,
that's all from tropic thunder.
That movies also the last time anyone's allowed to wear black face.
That's it.
That's right.
It's over now.
Like if Robert Downey jr tried to wear black face in tropic thunder to imagine,
just imagine blowback back.
Oh boy.
All the hurt feelings.
What happened?
Christina?
They fused enormous question of what happened.
I'm hoping you have a fresh take on it.
I'll tell you want to know what I think it is.
Really?
Yes.
Okay.
I think since Donald Trump became the leader,
and I think some people are so triggered by Daddy,
right?
Daddy's a little narcissistic at times.
Daddy's not very socially conscious at times and I think that's affected it
because if you say anything kind of insensitive than it's in align with that
regime,
maybe,
you know what I mean?
Even though you're,
maybe you don't,
I don't identify with everything.
Trump stands for it.
I like inappropriate humor.
Doesn't mean I aligned with him,
but I think because he doesn't give any sensitivity to these groups that are
marginalized,
it makes the marginalized people upset.
I also think that people have realized that you can get people in trouble by
pointing out the fact they're insensitive and you can come down on them hard and
when you do,
they move.
Things happen.
There's like an a reaction.
Yeah,
this is happening.
What's interesting is the impulse to destroy it started with shaming.
Fire then take away their income.
Yeah.
Make them lose their house.
Disappear.
Louie CK banished.
Go away forever.
Right.
I'm not ready for you to come back yet.
Redemption and house.
When is redemption allowed?
How soon has he repented enough?
Do we feel like he's earned that?
There's all kinds of stuff.
Yeah.
And then who's accused?
What are the grounds for accusation?
What's enough?
What's enough evidence?
Just somebody saying something.
It's good enough.
Believe all women,
which I believe obviously.
I mean,
who the fuck,
you know?
But then again,
yeah,
there are people who are allying who do say for sure,
but that believe all women thing.
Like what about Casey?
Anthony,
believe her.
You know what about Tonya Harding?
Believe her.
No.
Right?
He saw the movie.
Did you see the movie?
It's a funny,
there's a lot of dumb do you shouldn't believe.
Yeah.
There are people on on,
yeah,
exactly.
I only met her a liar with a vagina.
That's outrageous.
They have the giant is 10 wires.
There's a whole separate breed.
They're non gender specific.
That's right.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Minor.